a vengers endgame brought plenty of
changes to the Earth's Mightiest Heroes
and one of the biggest was to Thor who
put on a lot of weight fat Thor as he's
being called is dealing with a lot of
depression and trauma here's his story
from Black Panthers anger after his
father's murdered - iron man's post
Avengers panic attacks - Valkyrie
abandoning Asgard and drowning her
sorrows the Marvel movies have often
dealt with the psychological trauma that
comes with the life of a superhero this
time though it's on a completely
different scale in the MCU the ending of
infinity war is unquestionably the
biggest tragedy in the history of the
planet it's not just the billions of
people turned to dust but as we see an
endgame it's all life meaning that
Thanos took out animals - it's
devastating for the entire universe and
the heroes who are at the center of it
are no exception when the film shifts
its focus to five years after the snap
we see that each of the Avengers has
been dealing with the trauma in a
different way even before we get to Thor
it's not always healthy in what's
probably the most productive response we
see Captain America leading a support
group for survivors which works on a lot
of levels it highlights the empathy and
moral Center that makes Steve Rogers
such an appealing character and works as
a tribute to his fallen friend Sam
Wilson before he was an Avenger Sam was
leading a support group for veterans and
with him gone cap is doing his best to
carry on that legacy the others however
aren't doing so well in the way they
deal with tragedy
Hawkeye goes to an incredibly violent
extreme trying to personally enforce a
fairness that's absent in the loss of
innocent life Black Widow loses herself
and obsessing over her work trying to
fix everything she can while Tony
Stark's life post snap is far more
idyllic than the other heroes he's still
completely given up making the world a
better safer place which defined his
life is Iron Man he's refusing to use
his genius to help others because well
what's the point he tried it didn't work
time to move on these are all very
different in very relatable ways of
dealing with a traumatic experience
Bruce banners reaction to the snap is
worth paying close attention to both
because it represents the biggest change
for one of the characters and because of
the relationship he's had with Thor
throughout the history of the MCU
they first slugged it out on the
Helicarrier back in the first Avengers
film they've been competitors and the
buddy comedy of thor ragnarok put them
in direct contrast with each other it's
come up several times throughout the
films that since they hadn't met Captain
Marvel yet they both consider themselves
to be the strongest Avenger welcome
strongest Avenger Oh what for all their
similarities it's how they react to
their failures that shows how different
they really are since this character is
entirely built around making explosive
anger and the reaction to trauma a
literal physical change it makes sense
that it's the Hulk that we first see
reacting to the devastation that comes
along with Thanos this unstoppable force
of nature comes up against something he
can't beat through strength in infinity
war Pope learns the same thing Thor
learns at the beginning of endgame
sometimes physical strength is
completely meaningless and that's a
devastating lesson for someone who
relies on that strength is one of their
defining characteristics for the Hulk
the initial reaction is another one of
those unhealthy coping tactics he runs
away and hides
he won't even Hulk out when his life's
in danger leaving Bruce Banner free of
his dark side for the first time in
years instead of accepting this thing
he's wanted Banner comes to understand
that the Hulk is a part of him and as a
result he spends the five-year gap
essentially going through the
gamma-powered super heroic version of
therapy and working through his issues
to unify his personalities 80 months in
The Gambler
I put the brains and the Brawn together
and now they give me best of both worlds
back in the first Avengers film Bruce
Banner gave us the iconic line that
summed up his struggle with his emotions
I'm always angry
the hope we have an endgame however is
no longer driven by anger he has young
fans that want to take pictures with him
and he shares his lunch with ant-man in
a scene that's far more than just a
punch line this is a brand-new version
of the Hulk one who's not just smart but
kind and generous instead of being a
mindlessly angry walking temper tantrum
with the potential to destroy a city for
the first time in the franchise Bruce
Banner is happy because he's learned and
worked to change himself unfortunately
that's one thing Thor can't do in a lot
of modern stories about mythological
characters including recent comics about
Thor the idea is that the gods are the
embodiments of ideas unlike humans they
can't change their nature okay I thought
the world of you I feel what I'm gonna
find side by side forever but at the end
of the day or you and I mean Thor is the
god of thunder who storms in with a bolt
of lightning and a booming hammer laying
waste to his enemies he's an almost
effortlessly powerful warrior and the
entire arc of Ragnarok is devoted to the
way he learns that his strength and
power come from within himself not from
any of his magic weapons it's his
defining feature so what happens when it
doesn't work an endgame Thor sees
himself as personally responsible for
failing to kill thanos before he could
snap and when he finally did finish off
the mad Titan it was too late to fix
anything he goes through almost the same
thing that the Hulk does except that
he's made to watch as the last remnants
of his people are attacked and
eventually finds out that even his shiny
new hammer can't stop Thanos and time
for all his strength he failed if his
strength defines him but it couldn't
save the billions of lives lost an
infinity war what's the point
that's the existential crisis Thor's
dealing with an end game when we meet
back up with Thor five years after the
snap he's almost completely inert that's
a very common and very relatable symptom
of depression and so is the idea that
he's not just sitting around in the dark
being sad for all the film's
over-the-top visuals and jokes about his
weight the movie isn't a cartoonish
portrayal of what it's like to deal with
depression we see Thor laughing and
hanging out with his friends but when
he's confronted with the idea that he
could do something important the same
thing he's failed at before it just
doesn't matter
there's another element of his
depression that manifests itself in the
film - he's become an alcoholic
Thor's legendary appetite for beer has
always been a source of comedy in the
MCU films I don't drink tea what do you
drink
not tea end game shows us the darker
side of that like a lot of people with
depression including Valkyrie and
Ragnarok Thor is self-medicating and his
physical change is the result of that
sadly that's a pretty relatable element
for a lot of viewers - one of the
reasons Thor's new body was such a
surprise is that unlike a lot of end
games other callbacks there's no
precedent for it in the comics Thor has
undergone plenty of changes over the
years including the time he was a six
foot six frog for a few issues but he's
always been drawn with the heroic
proportions that you'd expect as far as
his mental state the closest we've
gotten to seeing a truly depressed Thor
came when we got a glimpse of a distant
future where Thor was the last surviving
Asgardian
like his movie counterpart all-father
Thor was dealing with isolation
depression and the toll of millennia a
battle that left him with one arm in one
eye
the main difference was that this Thor
was more than willing to take up his
hammer and fight although his goal was a
glorious death in battle that doesn't
mean the Thor comics have been free of
fat jokes for decades one of the most
prominent members of Thor's supporting
cast was Volstagg the voluminous one of
the Warriors three he's a once mighty
warrior whose waistline is just as
expanded as the inflated tales of his
glory while Volstagg was often depicted
as a braggart and more than a little
cowardly he's also always been a very
positive character who comes through in
dire situations also in an interesting
contrast of what we see with Thor he
once survived the destruction of Asgard
only to waste away from lack of food
before Thor found him and nicknamed him
Volstagg the thin all of that forms the
background but for some members of
endgames audience the possible intent
doesn't matter as much as what makes it
to the screen the simple fact is that
the reveal of fat Thor is absolutely
played for laughs and Thor's body is
used as a frequent punchline there are
cracks from our heroes about Thor having
Cheez Whiz running through his veins and
even the scene with his mother one of n
games most emotional sequences ends with
Frigga telling him to eat a salad part
of that undoubtedly comes from the fact
that over the past decade Thor has
evolved into a much more comedic
character than he might have been if
Chris Hemsworth didn't turn out to have
a talent for comedy he transformed
himself into a snake and he knows that I
love snakes so I went to pick up the
snake to admire it and he transformed
back into himself and he was like yeah
it's me and he stopped me that said once
he's done playing fat Thor Hemsworth
gets to go back to being well Chris
Hemsworth the fat jokes are bound to
sting regardless but coming from a dude
known for being super heroically ripped
and ridiculously handsome it definitely
feels like he's punching down for some
viewers the jokes that Thor's expense
were easy to forgive not only did they
see Thor's depression and its results as
relatable but the fact that his fellow
Avengers are lashing out is an equally
realistic depiction of how people around
them can react under stress these
characters have always been quick to get
snarky with each other and that's just
part of their appeal sometimes sometimes
I want to punch you in your perfect
teeth but even within the context of the
film we're still seeing superheroes the
ultimate good guys making fun of
someone's appearance context is
important but it's always worth
remembering that this is fiction and
calling anything realistic doesn't hold
much water in a movie where a guy with
rocket boots uses magic space rocks to
fight a 7-foot purple alien for some
critics it just raises the question of
whether we would have lost anything if
it hadn't been there or if Thor's
Depression had been shown in some other
way the flipside to the anger is that
for all of its flaws and the sniping
from other characters the action of the
movie never really presents Thor's body
as a problem the climax of that
emotional scene with Frigga is the
present-day post snap Thor summoning
Mjolnir and realizing that despite the
guilt he's been feeling for five years
he still as worthy heroic and Noble as
he has always been most telling at the
end of the movie where he truly regains
his godly power and makes a stand
against Thanos he doesn't just magically
transform back into his usual muscular
body
the only change to his physical
appearance is that his unkempt beard is
now neatly braided he still as hefty as
he was but he's also as strong as ever
as corny as it might sound all he really
needed was to talk to someone who
understands what he's going through
the fact that there's no physical
difference between the depressed
apathetic Thor of the beginning of the
film and the hero we see at the end
seems to indicate the filmmakers
sincerity in presenting the depression
not the weight gain is the problem to be
conquered still the jokes at his expense
are very much a part of the film and
it's hard to believe that Thor won't be
showing up in future MCU films with his
traditional jacked body builder physique
the way it's treated going forward is
going to go a long way in determining
how audiences look back on it here check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite superheroes are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the belt so you don't miss a single one
[Music]